[Music]
so we started talking to the mayor of
bandung in 2016 when he wanted to make
bandung a more livable city a more happy
city and increase the happiness index of
its citizens so he first got in contact
with him
through one of his partners the guy who
was leading the smart city initiative of
bendung
so we began talking and really had a lot
of discussion of how we can include the
citizens into creating new innovations
into getting involved in
making the city more livable
so we decided to go for a crowdsourcing
contest because indonesia is really an
interesting market in this regard they
are really keen on using social media
and these kind of platforms to
communicate so i think around that time
jakarta
was
announced to be the number one tweeting
city in the world so really the social
media usage in this country was really
high so it was a great way to connect
different people and to collect a lot of
different ideas and problems on an
online platform so really this kind of
pre-existing conditions in the community
allowed us to
use this method and we really wanted to
understand what moved these people what
were the problems that they had so
that's why we decided to really go for
finding problems finding out what the
needs of the people were what kind of
ideas they already had to solve them
really to get a better understanding of
the community of the people of what was
the issue at the core of the city of
bandung we didn't really have a lot of
expectations this was kind of the first
initiative regarding crowdsourcing in
indonesia we hope to get a lot of
submissions
because the mayor of bandung really has
a lot of
reach in the region so he is
what in asia is called the key opinion
leader what we may call in the western
world an influencer so he has a lot of
twitter followers who we expected to
reach a lot of people
but we never expected to really get so
many people to participate to join the
discussion to submit their problems to
submit their ideas and to contribute to
this contest so we were very kind of
overwhelmed of how well this kind of
initiative worked in indonesia
throughout the contest we collected more
than 1600 ideas and from all different
kind of topics from
transportation healthcare environment
education so the people really submitted
a lot of their problems that they had
and solutions that they would like to
see implemented overall more than 5000
people registered on the platform so
really a big amount of the
citizens really got engaged here and
actually took the step of taking part
actively not just reading about it not
just listening to what the mayor had to
say there were about 16 000
people visiting the platform during the
time of the of the contest but 5000
people actually actually signed up and
actively engaged with the community